[Musique]
ils viennent toujours là bas possible
après martin gray un homme broyé par un
drame qui a bouleversé la france entière
dans un incendie sur ce lieu même sa
femme et ses quatre enfants ont péri
brûlées vifs mais la vie a triomphé
l'homme ayant su reconquérir son propre
goût de vivre la maison reconstruite
le jardin replanter martin gray s'est
remarié il a deux nouveaux enfants sa
nouvelle femme en attend un troisième 30
millions d'amis est venu rendre visite à
cet homme au destin exceptionnel parce
que comme vous allez le comprendre
les chiens ont joué un rôle capital dans
sa vie
[Musique]
ça
et on doit dire martin gray ou martin
gray convaincre les français je pense
tout le monde connaît pas mates engrais
restera en france
est-ce qu'il sera un discret de vous
demander parce que nous ne sommes pas un
journal à sensation vous en doutez ce
qui vous fera indiscrètes vous demander
de nous raconter brièvement l'événement
capitale qui s'est produit dans votre
vie et qui est en partie due en partie
la raison pour laquelle sony vient je
pense que plupart des français et
connaissent son histoire notre histoire
si vous voulez vous savez que je suis
arrivé ici en train aussi environ vingt
ans après avoir traversé l'enfer du big
air j'ai connu les ghettos les ghetto de
varsovie les camps d'extermination de
treblinka où j'ai perdu toute ma famille
mal samedi entier sans hésitation le
seul rescapé de 17 ans mais après j'ai
connu l'affront chine en amérique
et puis si on reviendra en france à
contrer ma femme avec elle j'avais
quatre enfants un bonheur c'est qu'on
peut appeler peut-être bonheur extrême
et puis c'est un incendie de forêt qui a
ravagé sur la côte d'azur 1970 il ya dix
ans presque dix ans
toute ma famille ma femme et quatre
enfants sont disparue dans cet incendie
juste à côté ici donc il fallu survivre
il va nous vivre il fallut raconter tout
ce que j'ai connu il lui fallut
témoigner ensuite et ça que j'ai écrit
mon témoignage mon premier livre qui
s'appelle alors tous les miens d'arrêter
raconte traduit
[Musique]
la vie a repris dans cette maison du
souvenir coeur du drame
elle a été rebâti telle qu'elle était
avant le drame
tout ici est exorcisme la famille
nouvelle les chiens bergers allemands
ceux là même qui surveillait les
prisonniers du ghetto de varsovie et
maintenant avec ma femme nous a fait à
nouveau mettre la vie dans cette maison
on arrive déjà là parce que les enfants
sont là les animaux la vie commence à
nouveau
martin gray ces chiens existait déjà au
temps du drame nos sessions là
n'existait pas j'avais des autres chiens
bergers allemands qui sont mort si dans
les années d'efforts et une seule chine
qui me reste à cette époque là qui kiri
verne copenhague qui semaines mais elle
était tellement malheureuse les chagrins
éléments que si maintenant puisque je
suis remarié à nouveau j'ai des enfants
je pense que c'est bien s'entourer des
animaux bien poussoir pour les enfants
voilà de nouveau bestioles toute beauté
comme ça en pleine forme qu'il en
appelait à cette maison que de charme de
la vie vous êtes personnellement attaché
aux animaux et vous savez que moi
j'avais tout mon histoire de ma vie
était toujours lié avec des animaux
quand j'étais enfant avant que nous
avons été occupée par les allemands en
pologne
j'avais des chiens et des chats mais
quand peut-on être enfermé dans le
ghetto de varsovie il vient surtout des
plastiques des chiens et des chats
il fallait survivre nous mêmes il va
plus d'animaux dans les ghettos et je me
suis promis s'il jouerait survivre est
resté entouré des animaux parce que j'ai
besoin je veux c'est un sentir c'est
solidarité entre les hommes et animale
martin crête pourquoi d'hébergeur nom
viendrait beaujard humain j'ai raison
spéciale parce que pendant la guerre
quand j'étais enfermé dans le ghetto
quand cet intermède le camp
d'extermination de treblinka j'étais
mordu par le doj allemand avait
réellement qu'ils étaient dressées par
les bourreaux pour nous abattre nous
le prisonnier les juifs je tourne sept
ont abattu mordu par au bas ventre
je me souviens d'un mouvement car je me
suis évadé de ces camps de treblinka
l'ennui est allongé sous le camion et ce
chien qui a mordu dans le jour avant le
même chien qui est dressé par les
bourreaux il vient à mes pieds mais les
ché ils ne sont devenus des amis et ça
me prouver que les chiens sont
finalement c'est que l'on sait je veux
que le chien jamais fera de mal à
personne et tous être au programme
contre les benjamins qui ont en
attendant parlait qui sont mourèze voilà
voilà ils sont mauvaises doivent ils y
jouent avec des enfants ils sont plus
les mêmes qu'il mène valeureux
[Musique]
ah ah
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce terrain dénudée en face de vous c'est
l'endroit qui a brûlé tous et éreinté
tout mon site où les avons roulé et
maintenant je suis en train d'arracher à
replanter des salles comme je vais créer
à nouveau ma famille la vie à nouveau
reprendre ici à tenero je suis comme ça
les montants marié j'ai des enfants
troisième la ville doit arriver la vie
elle pousse en essence on va à bientôt
[Musique]
le
pour